gran espectativa en francia a pocas
horas de que se haga efectiva la salida
del reino unido- de la unión europea
tras casi medio siglo de presencia en
este bloque una expectativa que no es
para menos si tenemos en cuenta la
importantísima relación económica que
existe entre ambos países el reino unido
es uno de los destinos principales de
los productos de las industrias
agroalimentaria
automotriz espacial y aeronáuticas de
francia y a su vez este país es el
cuarto destino de las exportaciones del
reino unido- hay cierto alivio debido a
esos acuerdos alcanzados y firmados hace
algunas horas que en teoría para mitigar
el efecto negativo de el break city sin
embargo se espera que esa separación
tenga un efecto en el producto interno
bruto francés de 0.1 por ciento para el
año próximo con todo este panorama de
fondo y en medio de una crisis sanitaria
los franceses esperarán 2021 bajo un
toque de queda entre 8 de la noche y 6
de la tarde la mitad de las líneas de
metro cerradas aquí en parís
prohibiciones en todo el territorio
nacional para reunirse en lugares
y también en grupos de más de 6 personas
dentro de sus casas en las próximas
horas también el presidente manuel ma
chrome emitirá su tradicional discurso
de fin de año dirigido a los franceses